at this stage we assess that some
professional IRA organizational
infrastructure continues to exist but
has undergone significant change
contrary to what the Chief Constable of
the DA's and I claims the IRA has gone
away
a man has been murdered at the hands of
those linked to a party of government
this is unacceptable
your hopefully at the password is enough
these people had McKeon forward I mean
nobody
Kevon McGuigan had just arrived home
when he stepped out of his car hooded
gunman opened fire with semi-automatic
weapons the former IRA man had lived by
the gun and died by it the question is
whose gun the British government might
not want to know the answer his murder
has shaken the peace process to the
point where the devolved government at
the very heart of it is on the brink of
collapse he knew his life was in danger
Kevin McGuigan arranged his own funeral
for three months he'd been a marked man
the IRA had carried out an investigation
find him guilty of murdering one of its
commanders and sentenced him to death
its internal and it's how they do their
business they sorta died internally but
it's a big machine the big machine was
at war as they put it and that machine
was suddenly stopped over a course of
time I think what concerns people is the
the core components of that part of the
machine can be readily put back together
again and I think we've just seen
evidence of that Joc Davison was shot
dead in May he and McGuigan had been
partners in terrorism torn apart by a
violent feud the murder of an IRA
commander and the reprisal for his death
has put the Provisionals back onto the
spotlight if Shin Phan is held to
account it could signal the end of its
power sharing arrangement with the
Democratic Unionist Party
the DUP is not prepared to continue as
if nothing has happened
a man has been murdered at the hands of
those linked to a party of government
this is unacceptable as a first step
there will be no further meetings of the
Northern Ireland Executive unless we
deem that there are exceptional
circumstances sources close to the Kevin
McGuigan murder investigation have told
Sky News it leads to the very top of the
IRA detectives are likely to question to
man of senior rank who are considered
close to the Shin feign leadership Tok
Davis
like kevin McGuigan were wrong those
involved do not represent republicanism
they are not the IRA contrary to what
the Chief Constable of the PS and I
claims the IRA has gone away
the Provisional IRA was a force to be
reckoned with it claimed more than 2,000
lives during the Northern Ireland
troubles ten years ago it said it had
decommissioned its arsenal of weapons
and declared an end to its campaign of
violence if anyone knows the terror
group
Jared Hodgkins does a member for 25
years he spent 16 in the maze prison
provision eres no access although it
doesn't exist as a Revolutionary Army
committed the war against the British
steel what it exists as a small small
group of people who are left over from
the days of the Provisional IRA swore
against the British and we have the
first effect their funds and resources
and T financial interests and they exist
as a small group of armed and dangerous
people to protect those interests and
protect themselves what's your reaction
when Gerry Adams comes on the television
and says the IRA has gone away you know
a laugh out at Mustaine tonight if he
wants to keep saying the area's going
away you can keep saying that this was
he keep saying he was never in the IRA
but it makes you laugh because it's not
true because it's not true and because
everybody knows it's not true if it's
not true that the IRA has gone away the
symbolic gestures of the peace process
did not reflect reality
why was the Queen allowed to shake the
hand of its former commander not once or
twice but three times and why did the
heir to the British throne have a
conversation in May with the world's
most recognizable Irish Republican those
historic meetings took place on the
understanding that the Provisionals were
on ceasefire had decommissioned weapons
declared their war over if I or a guns
are on the streets it isn't just a
policing issue it's a political one
because the terror groups political wing
is in government here unionists only
agreed to share power with shin Fane
on the condition that the Republican
campaign of violence was over so the
allegation that the IRA is murdering
people calls into question the very
basis of its coalition with the
Democratic Unionist Party in Protestant
heartlands like the Shankill Road in
Belfast there will be a battle for
unionist votes in the next Assembly
election by pulling out of devolved
government the smaller unionist party
has piled pressure on the larger to call
time on power sharing but Arlene foster
the woman tipped to be the next First
Minister says her parties never been
fooled by shin Fenn let us not forget
that the IRA perpetrated some of the
most heinous crimes upon the people of
Northern Ireland I'm from a border
region of Northern Ireland I know only
too well what the IRA is capable of but
we thought that that was in the past we
were told back in 2007 that they were
committed to peaceful means we didn't
take them on trust we always looked for
evidence to see what was going on and
here we have a situation where the Chief
Constable of the Police Service of
Northern Ireland is telling us that the
Provisional IRA are still in existence
and some of their members were involved
in a murder if you want to see how much
is at stake here there's no better place
than the ancient walls of Derry the city
that witnessed Bloody Sunday when
British soldiers shot 13 people dead has
changed beyond recognition during the
peace process from our front door you
can see Derry wolf
it's home to Martin McGuinness now the
most senior Republican in government he
was right at the heart of the IRA do you
know who murdered Kevin McGuigan no I
don't but I do
believe absolutely that it was an
appalling brutal murder different labels
are put on these people you know former
members of this and the police say they
think they are members of that you know
of the IRA but
and my view they're dissidents they're
all hostile to the peace process they're
all enemies of the peace process they're
my enemies are the enemies of all of the
political parties on the assembly is
there anything more that Martin McGinnis
can do to persuade dating unionists that
you're committed to peace that the past
has been left behind well I have
committed you know I have committed
myself heart and soul to the peace
process over the course of the last 20
years I think that's made some impact on
unionist people in the north they
certainly made an impact on genius
politicians who find as a result of my
commitment and my party's commitment to
peace and democracy that they should
have the government with us do you feel
your own life is in danger because of
the decisions you've made in the course
of the peace process I never think about
that at all
I am absolutely totally committed and
dedicated to the ongoing success of the
peace process if I was to be concerned
about that I wouldn't leave the house in
the morning there are people out there
who are maliciously disposed to towards
my involvement in the peace process and
they want you know bad enough to take my
life all right long enough to know that
they have the ability to do that am I
going to let that put me off and my work
for peace not in a million years if the
Provisionals had gone they'd have taken
secrets with them like where they'd
buried victims simply known as the
disappeared Kevin McKee was one of them
42 years after his abduction and murder
the still existing IRA gave up its dead
DNA results have just confirmed that it
was his remains they located during the
summer his sister can finally give him a
Christian burial it sounds strange by
saying I'm so happy I'm a cop with for
the coffin commander's house I mean the
day he comes in here it's like Jesus
we've got our burglar back you know
we'll having had our brother and years
we didn't know what he was dead
I'll a will heaven I mean we've had we
miss certain so much you hopefully if
the password is
and if these people hadn't came forward
I mean none of the bodies what I'm gonna
find so when I say I'm grateful at least
I had that better conscience they come
forward
you know if they had an apology was
enough been getting anywhere today I
wouldn't be long ago you know a security
crisis was the last thing they needed at
Stormont failure to agree welfare reform
had already created political stalemate
in London Dublin and Belfast they're
fighting to keep the pace and bring
Northern Ireland across the line to
normal politics
we know that devolution is the best way
possible for Northern Ireland we believe
that it delivers for Northern Ireland
yes there have been huge difficulties
along the way but we believe it's a
price worth fighting for
so the IRA is accused of killing people
unionists are competing to be seen as
the toughest and the British and Irish
governments are holding crisis talks but
anyone who thinks nothing has changed
here has either forgotten how bad it was
20 years ago or is too young to remember
those days it's the fact things have
changed that makes this crisis so
destabilizing when men and masks are
waiting to fail any political vacuum the
stakes are high
you